[Music]
good morning this is the day the history
books will record as the day they signed
the agreement on ending the war and
restoring peace in Vietnam that is the
official title and this is Saturday
January 27 1973.
yesterday marked 50 years since the
Paris Peace Accords were signed an
agreement that formally ended the
Vietnam War
much has changed since then but half a
century later some stories remain Untold
including the experience of Porter
Halliburton a pow held for more than
seven years at the age of 83 now
Halliburton has written Reflections on
captivity an incredibly powerful book
from the man who was supposed to be dead
so this is it so this is it yeah in
Greensboro North Carolina Porter
Halliburton looks down on his tombstone
in memory of Porter Alexander
Halliburton killed in combat over North
Vietnam
but you weren't I weren't
[Laughter]
halliburton's plane was shot down over
North Vietnam in 1965. while on his 76th
Mission the government listed him as
killed in action
what no one knew is that he was able to
eject I didn't know that I was supposed
to be dead I found out I was dead
roughly the same time that Marty found
out I was alive
Halliburton left for Vietnam when his
daughter was only five days old
it would be 16 months before his wife
Marty learned he was a prisoner of war
when you were first captured did you
think you were going to be tortured
killed what did you think
I didn't know I it was all so uncertain
and so I was determined to try and
survive
for my family mostly and if I had been a
bachelor I don't know what I'd have done
whether I would
've ridden the plane in with the pilot
do you think he would have
sacrificed yourself died rather than
become a prisoner and face
whatever I knew it was going to be bad
but I didn't know how bad one public
incident was the first March of pows
through Hanoi in front of crowds who
threw objects and yelled
but it was far worse in isolation where
Halliburton was Shackled and tortured to
communicate the prisoners practice
something called tap code the word was
we may not be able to talk so here's
here's a code that we can use to tap
between the walls how would you like if
you're going to say hi to me how would
you tap that I would tap on two Taps
which means the
um the second row down on this Matrix of
five by five
and then three Taps over to the letter H
and then I would tap two tabs and four
taps over to the letter i
you said the reason why you were able to
be so effective whether it was tap code
or other things is it because the
Vietnamese didn't understand American
culture and American humor we found that
that was a weapon that we could use was
there ignorance of a lot of American
things
uh they didn't know what her middle
finger meant and so we used that anytime
there were cameras they had to figure it
out at some point well they did and I
think it must have been some Chinese or
Russian that you know was looking at
pictures that they take and they said
you know do you know what these guys are
doing to you when he continually refused
to divulge information the North
Vietnamese finally did something they
thought would break in
paired him up with a black prisoner that
was their idea of a worse place to put
me in a young southern white boy they
thought that race relations were so bad
in the U.S yeah that pairing you up a
white man with a black man was going to
be a disaster well and then telling me
that I had to I had to be his servant I
had to be his caregiver I had to do
everything for him which is something
that you embraced
I did Halliburton and fellow prisoner
Fred Sherry became lifelong best friends
their story was the subject of the book
two Souls indivisible Fred Cherry is
here this is right after the book came
out in 2004 and this is Jim Hurst the
author Lieutenant Colonel Jerry Cherry
died in 2016. both he and Halliburton
survived in Vietnam by accepting the
physical pain and changing their mental
Outlook I was on an emotional roller
coaster
and at some point I said there's nothing
I can do to get home any earlier than
when it happens
and so I'm not going to worry about it
I'm going to worry about what I can and
so I developed what I called long-term
non-specific optimism
long-term non-specific optimism right
I'm going home sometime but I ain't
worrying about when it is
when Halliburton was finally released
shortly after the Paris Peace Accords
were signed it was Front Page News
570 Americans captured by the Vietnamese
Communists in almost a decade of War
have now been freed Halliburton returned
to Vietnam 25 years later with Marty
neither had any idea what to expect the
people of Vietnam
I didn't want them to know who I was I
didn't want them to know I was an
American
and so I I had to say that I was
and they said America number one and
they put their thumb up
Marty Halliburton ended up making
frequent trips back and even began
teaching English as a second language
classes to Vietnamese
today in Greensboro Beyond writing
Reflections on captivity Porter
Halliburton has a book of poetry coming
out
but none of those words as good as they
are
are as profound as the ones on a piece
of stone that Halliburton visits from
time to time
the reminder of his death
That Never Was
when you look at this Tombstone today
what do you think
I'm so thankful to look down on it
instead of up
there's a reunion of pows in May they're
going to recreate the dinner when they
first visited the White House after they
were released 73 pows died in Hanoi 662
were released 377 are surviving to this
day
he lives such a rich wonderful complete
life today and he just what he passes on
and and I would presume in the book The
Reflections that he just what he shared
with you
amazing optimism long-term not specific
long-term non-specific I love that he
said as soon as he stepped off the plane
when he was released the first thing he
did as horrible as his time was and as
much as he was tortured he said he
forgave his captors wow because he knew
that if he held on to that hate it would
ruin the rest of his life a lot to learn
from that man wow great story Jack great
story